hey trailer commentaries the show where
we talk about that there show you
hopefully just watch this week bad boys
you stick around and get some deleted
scenes at the end T's next week on
trailer respond to comments from viewers
like yourselves I got some of the
baddest boys business with me oh boy
it's bad boy Dan Morrow oh she's just
got real I I'm so I'm so bad I took an
extra cookie when we did that I mean I
could get back and he ain't going
nowhere he can't be stopped now we're
gonna do yeah I recommend everyone
rewatched that video to get you in the
right headspace Ben Stiller's in it
puffy moves bad boys wanted to UM some
fun films I think I remembered them more
fondly then it was to revisit them I
like them both for different reasons I
think bad boy was one is like a decent
enough buddy cop movie and bad boy two
is like a sweaty fever dream like a
Michael big coke rush I had actually
never seen bad boys 2 until we were
doing this trailer yeah I've seen bad
boys one somewhat recently compared to
when it came out but bad boys 2 I
realized I've been the bay volution
chart like this was the exact middle
where the the Michael Bay we know is not
yet standing upright but he's also not
quite you know the rock this is I think
this is the exact middle point between
promising action director Michael Bay
who sometimes gives in to his worst
instincts and and the Michael Bay that
made transformers the last night and
that boys too is just missing will and
Martin Lawrence turning into robots yes
that's the only difference
there's the exact middle girl so
different that's what's weird about it's
weird to see two movies sequels yes to
say
director and totally aesthetically
everything about them is so different
from one to two I really changed the
whole thing and characters act
completely different in the first one
the Joey pants the Commissioner he's way
more like by the book by the
businesslike things have to get done
right now and then the sequel he becomes
just straight-up comic relief for most
of it shooting mostly he does play like
I'm gruff and then occasionally I'll say
something and this one each I was like
oh my buttons will come out that's how
far my players to any kind of
consistency a lot of fun stuff any kind
of consisted of Michael Bay characters
is a losing battle because even at the
end of bad boys to after he's been this
ridiculous butt trumpet guy he's like I
got friends in the CIA don't ask any
questions
it comes like military like a thriller
action comedy in Miami and then the last
third is just a no it's much like Top
Gun the next step in this movie is we
are at war yes because they they invade
Cuba killed Cuban military village where
US again
US military hardware is just to further
murder first we're at war right sister
have you no pride near rollicking
adventures eventually in depth at
Guantanamo Bay so we learn from howling
Kumar and Ed but to speak more on
Guantanamo Bay Australia for bad boys
wanted to
[Music]
before you see big star turned dad
vlogger Will Smith Daniel you you
introduced me to a dad vlogger I don't
know how it makes me feel cuz like on
one hand it's like Oh willow and Jaden
they seem pretty normal like down our
teenagers which conversely makes me more
annoyed by their public persona right
she's like I am from space yeah I'm
seeing with my ninth eye hanging out
there just like annoyed kids or like how
dad made us put on matching jammies yeah
and I keep having debates with willow
about baby it's cold outside my god just
normal kid stuff and then yes suddenly
they're like you know pyramids and like
have you heard of crystals and like all
that other stuff yeah so I make mixed
feelings but I do like I like this phase
of Will Smith's career of like I'm a
goofy dad yeah
I'm not so into didn't he do like stunts
for his birthday
no Michael Bay thing I believe it I'm
correct and that he bungee jumped out of
a helicopter into the Grand Canyon I
believe was what it was it's got stuff
hanging out Tom Cruise watching the
Mission Impossible movies you know like
hey I'm a big action star - yeah it's
like ya know it's time to rewind - like
I was hated video ever he kicked it off
or something yeah yeah well can't I'll
be his you tuber you know but hey who's
in Aladdin
so it's Tim and Miranda sings but us
yeah
is it inspiring or said that like Will
Smith and Jack Black
like other celebrities everybody wants
to be a game streamer right yeah you're
not trying to go career YouTube can be
fun it's just the pressure of like
having to make your living and do that
that's where I think it gets to be
addressed it doesn't have to go the
suicide for us big star turns Big Momma
Martin Lawrence revisit Michael Bay's
answer to the question can you make two
movies out of one reggae song chorus
what you gonna do when we come for you
and that's the pattern APIs next miss
knows man the bad boys bienvenidos a me
where the but field days turn to bud
field nights and like in Marcos to bad
boy cops dressed like they're signed to
Bad Boy Records the sad Weiner
oh sorry ain't getting none at home
Theresa his wound is fine it's other
things that were affected I've seen both
of these movies multiple times but until
we went through to do the oddest trailer
I forgot how focused the series are not
just one film not just a runner both
films very focused on Martin Lawrence's
sex as well the third movie maybe we
have a bunch of stuff on Twitter and one
of their main selling points in one of
their clips was him again being like I
haven't had sex in years yes
I look up weird talk I mean it's a more
consistent runner than like anything
else in the franchise yes point it's
like name three things about Will Smith
oh he's cocky he's like a smart dresser
he's like rich I just imagine the pitch
meeting where they're like all right
describe these characters like they're
opposites man like ones like crazy by
the book and the other ones a family man
and then one of the guys is super rich
and the other ones like the suburban dad
and then like one guy's womanizer and I
guess the other guy's dick doesn't he
gets laid all the time he gets erectile
disfunction man is what I would say it
crosses the line into relentless his
relentlessly focused done Martin
Lawrence this is sexual health well it
seems like they wound him in the second
yes solely to set up a protracted movie
long runner where his penis does not
work those arcs are actually more
fleshed out than anything else
those storylines have an ABC like they
have a beginning then I needed to pay
off in the third one I need oh yeah
third one at the end of it whatever
whatever explodes happened I don't want
to see that I just wanted to be implied
and she's like now it's time or
something like though I want full I want
Lawrence to hangdog I wanted to be cross
with Will Smith is like murdering people
and when Martin Lawrence is just making
missionary position fighting aliens it's
like crosscut like the end of The
Godfather like here so let's keep going
by the fact he's a serial killer
actually for first suit shooting them
from 30 yards while they running away
now that's not in point blank up close
in person tells what I'm talking yeah
yeah run a print that one yeah because
they they go into great links to talk
about how will as a trust-fund kid he
doesn't have to do any of this
and he really really loves killing
people and there's like a lot of really
gruesome stuff where he's like just
digging around in bodies dead bodies
Paul right that's the weird thing is
it's it's it's not only like he likes
killing like he's gung-ho that's been in
other cop movies but he loves like gore
and visceral like he loves disgusting
his partner buddy arcing him to be
around corpse it's very strange
I did one of my pitches for that one was
like he became a cop so he could hunt
the world's most dangerous game man yeah
yeah there's so much of him like this
deep in a body then yeah and what is
Michael Bay have for corpses like
there's a lot of corpse work there's a
lot of stuff in movies and one of them
is particularly egregious but they're
mostly like for Laughs right he finds
gore and like viscera hilarious six
underground to the Netflix one oddly
also has a fixation I'm like super Gore
but used as a joke like as a punchline
are you saying these corpses are the
feet of Michael Bay movie
which of course is just like bodies
being crushed during chases or whatever
there's a lot of like punchlines of like
a head exploding or something yes like
yeah it's like weird yeah I like to see
a Michael Bay horror movie I think
that'd be fun yeah I've seen I've seen
several that I would categorize this
[ __ ] let's keep going think for each
other but don't worry ii think they'll
do it in a gay way maybe there are
pictures of your lover oh cool you get
it cuz they're not gay no Mike why don't
you just give it a little kiss so they
feel better
get it I really appreciate you no that's
not gay get it still hurts from what you
did to it get it a bunch of men hugging
and kissing fart joke yeah this movie
we're talking about it's like it moves
it's such a breakneck ADHD pace yes
there's no time to do anything except
for like the most base obvious
observation about whatever's on the
screen at the time yeah Michael Scott
Rose yeah that's the type of humor yes
let's keep going they'll be joined by
their captain a walking countdown
clogged we got 72 hours we got four days
he'll goes down in four hours that means
you guys got two hours to [ __ ]
as classic Michael Bay female characters
like wife baby ballbuster I told you to
play by the rules
secretary threatened with revenge poured
hot therapist who has sex with her
patients favored prostitute underage
Megan Fox and big booby corpse these
movies age like a Michael Vick Jersey I
wonder what big movie corpse was
credited as we should look better almost
promise you would she's better than us
because she was referred to only in the
movie as bimbo yeah you always imagine
when someone's like mom mom I finally
did it I'm gonna made a big movie what
do you plan that doesn't matter corpse a
bimbo the human centipede very close to
each other my rents paid though dead
naked bimbo middle of Human Centipede
[Laughter]
prime is way
I'm doing an illegal favor for you or
that happens to be highly illegal
Sally honest I don't think gotta weigh
in illegally you got to put a word to it
looks like secret illegal and these
killer cops will use every michaelbay
ISM in the book to get it done like
circle shots military worship former
Delta Intel and demo his view of the
world is so insane and like I would
imagine demeaning to the military
because these guys have no connection to
will and and Martin it there now but
they come out of the woodwork to commit
a war crime country I've been wanting to
kill Cubans for years oh I just need the
thinnest of excuses yeah some guys
detectives in trouble let's bomb these
guys are just they're just deputizing to
like local Miami cops cops are the truth
they're all Delta Force I think it works
that way
I mean oK we've seen the wire we know
what drug cops do like they listen to
phone tap don't eat any whole bars in
Afghanistan
okay let's keep going to tag along I
kill again f-bombs I don't know what the
you're talking about yes you do know
what the I'm talking about you body bomb
balls
there's a highway there
the entire minutes
[Applause]
right before that somebody was like you
guys faked that for guys all just
literally standing around staring at a
landmine four of them yeah just go back
it's a little it's a little like Miami
Vice action spectacular some of those
shots where you can just see like the
charges were planted just to create this
huge I mean yeah they are just as they
were exploding all of Cuba it's just a
car driving be on fire right let's at
the end of bad boys one like the first
time I saw it in theaters it's like the
explosion is like eight times larger
like airplane hangar and it's just like
loading into a truck at a nightclub
alright let's finish up you know either
truck and there's something that you're
more on with the attention span of a
nine-year-old boy joke you phone [ __ ] so
strapped in with the movies that made
Will Smith into an action comedy
superstar what are you a cop or model
and make Martin Lawrence the guy stuck
next to people trying to become action
comedy superstars that elevated to
sitcom actors in a way that couldn't
even be done today
because who from TV could even do this
now fleabag and young Sheldon aquafina
and Ed O'Neill come on just drop the old
guys again but no Michael Bay this time
so tired bar joke nor tail Miami edy
baba yaga anger middle-management drug
bring it on phony Montana two sets of
actors playing essentially the same
characters crazy snitch Haitians Grand
Wizard we got all right I know Joker was
in this I'm a stand-up comedian
Michael Bay casting women that's why you
got the job cuz you look good in a
bathing suit Michael Bay directing women
City strutting Michael and people are
putting extra stank on Mike's name's
Mike loud Mike Lowrey Mike Larry you
wanted Mike Lowrey you got him lethal
brother when doing a gun at a landmine
which explodes allowing another guy to
headshot the bad guy who lands on
another landmine which explodes my
vision Michael Bay's Mona Lisa next to a
Hummer yeah that's good that last
explosion where he falls is really well
Smith's character saying he had an
erection
[Laughter]
who's in part to just part to a couple
haha sprinkled throughout one he was
still building the brand playing more of
like he's like he's the super cool suave
like the most badass guy and then the
second one is really where they're
playing up like adrenaline junkie
violent loves to shoot what is so effing
stupid is the the whole conceit of the
first one is it's like a body switch
comedy or like it's like a missus yeah
we've known these guys for five minutes
before they're pretending to be each
other for the whole movie and they're
pretending to be one another for a
person who would be funny for a scene
like oh she only trust Mike pretend to
be Mike but then you clear it up dumb
all right let's see some blades him and
meet Mike and Marcus two drug cops who
look like they were kicked out of new
addition for selling ecstasy two drug
cops doing Bobby Brown cosplay yeah
because these boys got to do bad is to
do good and to do more good they got to
get more bad twenty two cars and a boat
totally cuz it's good boys is bad bad
doers good at doing bad have no chance
against a couple of bad good doers bad
and good fart joke you far far gayer up
for Michael Bay spree transverse
practice wings featuring all your
favorite Bay isms like product placement
this happened to be one of the fastest
abduction cars on the planet zero to 60
in four seconds waiting headshots
and the assumption that you're a [ __ ]
with the attention span of a
nine-year-old there we go that's the
contempor the viewer we crave hate me
daddy story
you ain't never phone to felt like me
I'm going she's a fast reunion yeah but
it's a starring dirt cover policeman
let's because all of these stories babe
to these cops blue vibes splatter they
willy style miami twice
okay what kind of Club has in the query
part that looks into the men's room
that's girls hairless you know want to
see that wait so one is a handsome loose
cannon the other is a grumpy dad they
fight drug dealers say kidnapped women
and get yelled at by their captain but
they're both black do you think we
wouldn't notice y'all just make lethal
weapon into much faith use it for the
title yeah well there you go that's all
the footage we got let's dive into some
fan questions yeah linger senghor writes
question for Spencer to ignore or mock I
think these movies have moments of fun
amidst the horrific famous what do you
all think would have made the better I
won't mark this this is a good question
and I don't hate them I know we all poke
fun at them because they're easy films
to poke fun at but they are like
frenetic and entertaining and I think
that like I feel the same way about
Michael Bay movies that I do about like
Tim and Eric say where it's like I loved
it for about 12 to 15 minutes at a time
yeah it's like too much to break I think
this is great it's just an overwhelming
stupefying movie experience yeah maybe
different movies anymore focus perhaps I
feel like what the state don't need to
be to plus in this movie for example bad
boys too from the rock another Michael
Bay movie is the rock is pretty focused
on like a central conceit and a location
and there's lots of set pieces and
there's a lot of stuff happening but
it's it's it's fairly contained and I
think as that when I say this is like
the middle point between that Michael
Bay and transformers Michael Bay's this
is bad boys - it's because that's I
think what spun transformers eventually
out of control was they just threw 5,000
things at you and and none of it all
connected together so yeah I think
perhaps in the second one a little maybe
a little more focus yeah it's just it's
not always like sometimes less is more
like a few really tight well done action
scenes means you don't need 30 and every
with bad boys - it's just like it's just
too much like you could cut off the
whole cube apart and just kind of wrap
the story up but it would probably be a
better movie just like you know you can
still have a lot of big action but it
doesn't need to be 30 minutes of action
and probably spend at least like five or
six minutes per movie just stealing cars
like just taking like look that cars
running let's get in there Jackie I feel
this way with the Transformers movies -
it's like it it blunts the impact when
I'm watching an hour of yes like if you
condense that down but make it really
tight like John wick or something it is
more impact totally kg crossover catch a
nice crossover right why no mention of
Reggie a lot of people shown a lot of
Reggie love because he was in one scene
the trophy like you can't date my
daughter
okay it's so over the top so whether
they're legitimately making the kid
through oh my god this man is a
psychopath yeah crazy pretending to be
crazy but as we've seen in every other
scene of this movie he's legitimately
crazy
he had no trigger discipline like his
finger was on the trigger so if he
accidentally shoot that kid I don't
think he would have felt bad about it no
he would have plunged his fist into
I'm sorry I can't believe I didn't mean
when he gets addicted to killing people
who knows the problem it would have been
like a shame black funny being there
alright tuba in man I'm not a fan of the
hole every studio needs a cinematic
universe but it seems like bad boys
would lend itself to a bad boys extent
no I'm just gonna stop that LA's finest
which no one can see because it's I
didn't even know what it's like I
remembered that it was happening because
I was like when I was looking stuff up
it already started they're already done
with season 2 yeah yeah I don't know
what that is it's a spin on TV show
about Gabrielle unions character no way
that's Gabrielle she's like a drug
vice cop is what sir - here's a partner
someone famous but is it it all like the
same tone of bad boys - yeah it's like a
cop okay
what's the poison of like the the penis
doesn't work jokes and like ah
does she like accidentally take Molly
and like play with the corpse might be
like I believe her partner who again I'm
blanking on but who is incredibly famous
and it's more like just maybe she had
like a kid or something like that right
it'll be like okay
and Mark Robertson finally at minute
alphas Co no minute three 44 seconds why
is there Raptor Oh break it down for him
there you must be new here
we have how to explain this okay
Talon way back in the day for a long
time we were very obsessed with the
talking Velociraptor Jurassic Park 3
this says Alan and so the dream sequence
but we just loved it so much and so when
we did the Jurassic Park 3 trailer we've
heavily featured Alan to the point where
the transitions were Alan yes Pam and so
then I think just for fun we started
hiding them or Kevin our editors started
hiding them for trailers so the
Allen was hidden in the background of
some trailers but then we did the
trailers for Avengers infinity war Allen
was dusted in the sky and snaps so then
Allen disappeared for a while and then
Allen came back through the portals in
endgame and now Allen is now I'm behind
in hiding almost every trailer although
I think there's one the two that we
didn't put them in and people drove
themselves crazy looking for them yeah
you're not crazy we forgot what to do
most honestly Kevin and Kevin we there's
no guidance Kevin is brilliant at
finding the places for them Kevin will
hide an Allen Raptor which is now
transformed to just a Velociraptor yeah
it used to be the actual Raptor saying
Allen yeah now it's just we've been
doing these for seven years
we just like to throw in a little gives
you a reason to go back through all your
faves and try to find the talking
dinosaur that's why yeah all right great
thanks y'all that's all for this week
come back for next week sorry sorry
that's too obvious whatever it's okay
[Music]
you'll be back man because you like that
movie and you want to hear us make fun
of it and and I hope y'all will join me
so we'll see you then thanks for
watching so long
[Music]
you